mon coeur bat vraiment pourquoi on va
parler de tout notre invité ses eve
angeli merci au nom des neiges et
l'avait lui je vis dans le sud est oui
on a la belle vie en vie dans le sud on
dirait le sud le temps dure longtemps
dit madame ne vous plaît pas dans le
nombre d'écoutés pas des autres ah
j'adore j'adore les pointes j'aime les
animaux donc tout va bien quand tu me
fasses ça me fait toujours partie
continue et touche eve angeli et laval
alors content de l'avoir très très très
bas aussi j'aime beaucoup j'aime
beaucoup cette paire si c'est votre
cible jean michel maire aime pas c'est
long les poils away l'hébergeur golden
je peux le laisser pousser à bouaké
n'est pas 2,6 lui peut tout faire ainsi
que les choses mais sincèrement ce
n'était pas le but de montrer mes seins
après je les cache ah oui je vois ça oui
c'est plus que dans la rolls jeudi j'ai
envie que tout le monde n'y a pas de
tabou que les gens fassent ce qu'ils
veulent qu'ils acceptent leurs
différences
moi ma différence était d'être un peu
une blonde fofolle de temps en temps
mais je les assume
avec c'est extrêmement fatigant d'être à
côté des ventes de livres elle commande
comme si elle était la télé à chaque
fois que d'elle mme badia temps où tout
elle te parle
la plage devait live aid
je vous demande et je commençais des
proverbes vous devez les terminer tant
va la cruche à l'eau qu'à la fin elle se
brise ou bien oui on n'attrape pas des
mouches avec du miel
non mais tu as mais là c'est le bon donc
je dois aussi me regarde je lui dis que
je laime commandes à bon chat bon chien
non
[Musique]